hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again we
have a little bit of a small video
talked about today but it's a really
nice info about a potential season 12
leaked breach map that'll either
possibly I mean who knows if it's even
in season 12 but might be midway through
the season who knows but it's a leaked
breach map we're gonna be talking about
that today so as always like the V if
you do enjoy subscriber for new I
covered the informational site a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch it's in the
leaks even to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely subscribe the channel
and with that let's get started so I
need a preface a few things really
quickly that are very important
throughout the rest of this video I want
to give a quick shout out to East
champion on reddit for even posting a
huge analysis about this as well as Sir
spoon who is in my Twitter stream today
also if we want to follow me on Twitch
link will be in the description down
below I'm in streaming just about every
day for the newest drop season that's
happening we get in-game rewards for
just watching my stream so if we go do
that she'll have to serve spoon for
letting me know about this and I will
not be showing the video on screen for
obvious reasons that being copyright
Ubisoft does not like it when you show
stuff that is not even in the game and
this seeing as this has not been in the
game yet and we can kind of confirm that
they will most likely copyright strike
the video and you won't be able to see
this video so if we do want to see the
link I will provide a reddit post if you
want to look at it after the video
before the video or while I'm talking
it's gonna be a small little like 10
second video so if you do want to see
that click the link in the description
down below cuz it'll be very very useful
but yes you heard the title and you
heard me in the beginning right this
could possibly be a leak leading to the
new breach map which may actually
feature the new Wulin in a possible
season 12 release as we know in season
11 we got a new breach map for the
Vikings and obviously we all love breach
it's a really good game oh it's probably
my second favorite aside from Tribute of
course if said nobody plays that so
hopefully that'll be the next season
because obviously all they release all
these new maps every season and no one
can really play them besides like harbor
which was in season 9 because that was
Dominion anything that isn't Dominion or
breach no one's really gonna play cuz
the game mode is too short and there's
not enough player so basically it's a
dead game mode besides those two and
also some other people have been saying
that this is going to be a remake of
Kazan Castle and either way I'm still
cool with that but the thing is is that
while the Wulin and the samurai are both
Asian countries you know being very
different one as Chinese one is Japanese
the samurai being Japanese the woman
being Chinese East champion here on
Retta has also developed a big analysis
explaining some of the things that each
faction
as differently depending on their
history and all that stuff in their
culture and Healy and this leads me to
believe and him to believe as well and a
lot of people in the comments that this
is going to be a woolen map centered and
not a remake or a completely new samurai
map so real quick in the video if you're
looking on reddit because obviously I'm
not going to be posting it you're going
to be seeing your man Gunder doing a
standard execution that she has one of
the very basic ones on a hito kiri and
it's going to be on some type of Asian
themed map and right away you're
immediately going to be thinking that
that is cos on Castle because the giant
temple the like I said he distinguishes
this very differently he and a lot of
people from the discord on the foreign
or whether that be just woolen or the
foreigner discord in general have
noticed a few different changes that and
notice some key features that they
distinguish for example the floor tiles
and a lantern do not match the samurai
map Kazan Castle design true they could
have added new assets but given its the
current maps in the game use of tends to
reuse assets a lot just like its store
stronghold it has a lot of
characteristics and assets typical of
other Viking maps it is very unlikely
for the new assets to be unrelated to
the next hero and this video has a lot
of new assets that don't really match
the samurai one and it's also been
confirmed that for a long time that the
Wulin will eventually get their own Maps
and will maybe possibly join the faction
war and this might be that step to doing
it I will show some images on the screen
of a kind of a replica of what it looks
like within the map so you can kind of
understand what I'm talking about
I just won't show the things
specifically but there is a palace in
the very background of the video as they
very pronounced through if with tape
flares and archers are much higher which
is more common in Chinese architecture
very woodland style it is also missing
the fish statues common in the samurai
architecture and in the color palette
seems to resemble something along this
line as you're seeing on screen this is
very similar to the pit to the picture
here is very similar to the one in the
video on top of that there's also the
stock image I'm showing on screen of
some of the very colored and weren't lis
painted rafters within the temples and
this also matches the video as well this
Chinese architecture has not been seen
in the samurai maps or if it has it's
been very very slim and very different
we've also seen the samurai capital and
none of its buildings including the
palace which were painted in such a way
the only map that comes close to this
would be the temple Garden map there's
also a couple insignias on the ground
one of them is the happy-go-lucky
insignia which is an embossing only
available to the woman which further
proves the point because that insignia
is located on the floor of the palace
once again further improve
on this point that is most likely going
to be the woven style breech mat some
people have also noticed that some of
the banners that are within the map are
also very traditional Chinese banners
that have also been in the game total
war Three Kingdoms and I'll show the
image on screen of what the banners look
like in total war and these are very
similar if not the exact same banners
that are also within the new breach map
and once it gonna have to clarify that
the Wulin
are Chinese and the samurai are Japanese
so anything regarding any samurai
culture is going to be more
japanese-style anything resembling
anything Chinese will definitely follow
with the blue bin and so far this whole
video it's been majority of everything
has been all Chinese culture and
tradition as you can see these banners
are a lot more Square and blocky whereas
the samurai ones especially on the one
map I believe it's temple garden or one
of the maps that is already present
within the game is a lot more thinner
and more of a triangle base some of them
do have attached streamers at the end as
you can see from the Chinese one but
they're very few and far between thus
proving this is more of a Chinese style
map within the image as well you can see
a sculpture that is called a shi shi i
do apologize if i messed up that name
basically it's this little guardian
lying that is holding an orb and where
else have we seen those orbs according
to the post the Wulin emblem the Wulin
emblem is a dragon holding an orb and if
that orb is not an orb then it's going
to be something else smaller maybe a
smaller shi shi but usually it is a
guardian lying holding something in its
right paw and pressing down on it and in
this case the Wulin emblem is a dragon
holding an orb which really fits well
with the guardian lion and as a closing
statement for him all together these
features point towards the map being
more Roulin centered and not Samurai
that would suggest that art time
approaches for the Wulin characters to
finally get a breach map which would be
super cool as always I just want to
thank East champion for the write a post
like I said it'll be down in the
description down below and none of this
would have ever came to light if this
video wasn't least as well as him
providing a super in-depth analysis on
everything so huge shout out to him this
video would not be possible without him
as well sir spoon in my live streams
that mentions of this to me while I was
streaming today so thank you for it to
both of you for doing that you're doing
God's work yeah but let me know in the
comments below what you guys think about
this I think this is really cool I
cannot wait for the woman to have a
breach map it's been way too long the
woolen have been in the game for about
three seasons about two before and it'll
be really cool if they can finally get a
map centered around them seeing as they
were just kind of put in in the game and
without any other assets like any Maps
or any type of faction war so hopefully
they do get added to the faction war
because that would be really nice to see
a four wasteful
between the factions that was a little
breach map to kind of help them I know a
lot of people have been saying that a
lot of the characters like the woman are
very nomadic and they like to just
attack and not really have much defense
but I could totally understand that they
need to have at least some place to
house and I think this is gonna be that
map yeah guys that's gonna be the end of
the beta hopefully guys did enjoy it
like I said thank you to East champion
and sore spoon for having this video
basically without them this wouldn't be
possible so thank you guys so much for
that can't give you enough thanks
throughout this video and let me know
what you guys think
definitely check the video and let me
know like I said I still think it's
going to be a woodland centered map and
worst case scenario if it's not a woolen
map it's going to be a new samurai
breech map or a remake of kazan castle
which as you've got guys have known if
you've been on my twitch streams is
easily one of my favorite breach map so
I'm totally cool with whatever option
this is as long as this comes true and
they need to preface of course that this
is only a leak none of this is actually
might even come true this could be just
completely fake or this is totally
confirmed that will be coming next
season we have no idea we have to wait
for the developers to let us know about
that as always like the VP do enjoy
subscriber for new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the boundless changes to here
updates the Patrick's and the leaks if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world
before never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
and with that guys thank for watch the
video and peace out enjoy the rest of
your day
[Music]
you